blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right let's start today with
a coveted update we haven't done this
for a while and increasingly the numbers
in the united states
are looking better and better as
vaccination takes place we've seen the
slowdown due to vaccine hesitancy we
will talk about it
we have also now seen evidence that the
vaccines work well enough
against all major variants we will talk
about
that momentarily but first of all cases
cases which peaked at more than 255
000 cases per day in mid-january an
outrageous
number uh not illegal but certainly an
immoral number as i like to say
cases are now down under 50 000 cases
per day
for the first time since october of
2020. it's been seven
months since cases have been this low
down to about 47 000 per day as of
yesterday
this is now down more than 80 percent
from the peak
in mid-january and these numbers should
continue down
and look even better by memorial day
certainly by mid-june
as far as deaths go deaths peaked in
late january
at nearly 3 500 deaths per day
more than a 911 every single
day and those are now also down more
than 80 percent to about 675 a day still
horrible
but dramatically lower and understand
that daily deaths in the u.s
have not been below 700 a day since july
of last summer
so that is going very much in the right
direction deaths as low as they've been
in basically 10 months
now globally cases were coming down and
are coming down in the u.s
globally we did see a spike led by
countries like
india and brazil among others that has
also turned around not by much but
globally cases are now down about three
to four percent
from the peak that happened about 10
days ago we hope
that the global numbers will also
start coming down more significantly as
vaccines get to more and more countries
and we will speak momentarily about joe
biden coming out in support of lifting
or not enforcing patents on vaccines i
actually
don't think that's going to make a
difference but i'm going to tell you why
in the next segment
earlier this week i did tell you that
vaccination
is a growing problem in the sense that
supply is now exceeding demand in many
places
and we've seen average daily doses
decline from their high of about 3.4
million a day
now down to just 2.1 million doses per
day over the last week
that's not good but it will still get us
where we need to go
as long as it continues but the decline
in
doses led joe biden to announce a new
vaccination
initiative earlier this week we talked
about it yesterday cvs pharmacy has
already met the call they are going to
be offering
walk-in vaccination no appointment
necessary
at thousands of pharmacies across the
country
but the really good news about vaccines
is they
work on the variance of concern dr
eric topple former guest on the show
published yesterday a great infographic
showing us that of all of the relevant
variants so far there's the british
south african and brazilian
then there's the new york california and
india variants we have at least some
evidence that the vaccines work
for example with the uk south africa and
brazil variants
we now have lab studies randomized
clinical trials
and real world evidence that the
vaccines work well enough on those
variants
that if we keep vaccinating we can get
out of this for the new york california
and india variants we don't yet have the
randomized controlled trials
but we have lab studies and we have real
world evidence so
we have a path out of this moderna and
pfizer
at minimum are working on boosters that
will be tweaked for the variants
for the fall or winter so the path is
clear
by memorial day we will have a better
situation than we have today
and a little deeper uh you know early
summer
it will be even better if people keep
getting vaccinated
let's talk next about the patents
big big news joe biden yesterday came
out
in full support of lifting patent
protections
on coronavirus vaccines to help produce
more vaccines
globally the biden administration said
that
we need a breakthrough for international
vaccination vaccination happening quite
well in the united states and well in a
few other countries
but there are lots of countries that
don't even have vaccines on the
immediate horizon right now
and joe biden has now said let's do it
let's suspend intellectual property
protections
uh to ramp up vaccine production
and this is something joe biden has been
increasingly under pressure to say
it's not doesn't appear to be something
joe biden can actually
do but the reasoning is clear
we have a global health crisis these are
extraordinary circumstances
we need to produce as many doses as
quickly as possible and this would be a
case where
while you can respect conceptually
intellectual property protections and
patents and copyright
you can make the case this particular
situation
warrants lifting those protections now i
have to tell you for me there are two
stories here
first of all is the story that
joe biden is being pushed left i mean at
this point
on paper this may be the most
progressive administration in history i
i
i we have to understand what we're
comparing to
but uh this is something that big pharma
was completely against
they uh got expensive lobbyists pushing
for it
not to be done for there to be no
lifting of patents
and while joe biden can't actually do it
biden standing up to them and saying
this should be done
is a really big deal if you look at joe
biden's position on health care it's to
the left of obama if you look at joe
biden's position on taxation it's to the
left of obama
on paper this may be the most
progressive administration in history
now
we've never had you know bernie has
never been president
so we have to understand what that means
for those who said joe biden could not
be pushed left
he clearly has been at least to some
degree now here's my concern about this
entire vaccine thing that vaccine patent
thing
i agree that the patents should be
lifted
i agree that as many places as possible
should be given whatever they need to
start manufacturing vaccines as quickly
as possible
there's no question whatsoever that
being said
i don't think the lifting of patents is
actually going to get us out of this
mess
why in researching what it would take
for places that are not yet producing
vaccines to start producing vaccines
you could be looking at two years of
time
to build the infrastructure to produce
vaccines
if you start today so while i agree that
the patents should be lifted
and there are reasons for the future
that it would be great to set that
precedent in a global pandemic and all
i'm with it i'm with you i think this is
a great thing that joe biden has said
if it takes two years to build the
infrastructure if you don't have it to
start producing vaccines if you start
today
and who could start today you've got to
find locations you have to figure out
where are these
factories going to go if it takes four
months to start
and then it takes two years to do and
then the entire vaccine production and
distribution would take several more
months
we are looking at new vaccine production
if patents are lifted today that
wouldn't deliver vaccines until the end
of 2023 it's just too late i don't want
to be a party pooper i don't want to
rain
on anybody's parade but it's not clear
to me
that this is anything more than um
at least for the next two years a
theoretical or academic question
it should be done and for the future
pandemic
i'm with it again i'm with it i'm with
it plea please don't write to me saying
david how dare you be against it no i'm
for it
but when i see all these people on
facebook saying we could just get out of
this if the vaccine patents were lifted
moderna did say it won't enforce its
patent there's other aspects of the
production
that moderna doesn't control which have
intellectual property protections i get
that
uh i just don't see how this gets us out
of the pandemic any sooner
if i'm missing something let me know the
right decision
i don't actually think it will get
vaccines into people's arms
any sooner for this pandemic let me know
your thoughts i'm on twitter at
deepakman
quick break great show today
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
if you just can't get enough show every
day
if an hour isn't enough there's an extra
15 to 20 minutes available every day
it's called the bonus show and it's one
of many great
membership perks sign up at
joinpakman.com and you'll get that bonus
show
delivered to you in audio or video
whichever you prefer every single day
joinpakman.com is the place to do it
i also want to invite you to subscribe
free to the david pakman show subreddit
with now more than
30 000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed
at davidpakman.com reddit this morning i
saw some interesting posts
including one that asked so do
anti-vaxxers think that their friends
will still hang out with them
one of the easiest steps you can take to
reduce covet risk
is to not see anti-vaxxed people that
you might know
even though i am now vaccinated and
fairly comfortable returning to more
normal activities i will definitely
avoid anyone that is anti-backs
says this viewer do anti-vaxxers think
people won't avoid them we have been
avoiding risky activities for a year so
do they think people will just start
hanging out with them again maybe
friends deciding not to see anti-vaxxers
will nudge them towards getting the
vaccine i think there will be that to a
degree
i think it depends on what part of the
country you're in uh but
i know that much to the chagrin of those
who are now suddenly want medical
privacy
i regularly am saying to people are you
vaccinated i was invited to something a
couple of weeks ago and i said is
everybody vaccinated and i was told
uh yes everybody is and i said great
okay i'll be there
and um when i was invited to a different
thing
uh three weeks ago and i was told well
you know of the four couples
two are not vaccinated uh i said yeah
it's not for me i'm just i'm not doing
indoor stuff with unvaccinated people
right now it just doesn't doesn't
really make sense even though i am
vaccinated outdoor i will do
i think that will be an issue and i
think that's a really good uh
thing in if it influences more people
into getting vaccinated for sure
um another user says the party of free
speech
looks to cancel liz cheney for speaking
against trump
yeah this is i'm glad that this is is
being um
uh exposed the incredible double
standard on cancellation and free speech
the side that has been claiming to be
all about free speech
and claiming to be all about not
canceling people
is now trying to cancel liz cheney
they're trying to get her
uh removed from her leadership posts
they're trying to get her off of
committees they want her
primaried and removed because she had
the audacity to think for herself
on impeachment and she had the audacity
to
um say what should be really
uncontroversial which is hey joe biden
won
and the election wasn't rigged and of
course it's much of this
free speech for us but not for you
except it depends unless you disagree
but
if we like it then of course we'll
defend it it's always been a pathetic
hypocrisy
it should be pointed out and the liz
cheney cancellation attempts are only
the latest example
and then lastly a user claiming that
tucker carlson inspired assaults have
started
so i want to be clear that there has
been a horrible
attack uh in new york city by an
individual
who came up to another and said take off
that mask
and beat them and we have no particular
reason to think
that the assa the attacker was inspired
by tucker carlson's recent rants
saying if you see people outside wearing
a mask tell them take the mask off
we have no reason to think that but the
tucker carlson
statements the tucker carlson rants
about uh being against masks
are the type of thing that we often
describe as stochastic
terrorism in this case it's not
terrorism it's stochastic
or ism or something like that where
if you have a large enough audience some
people will hear you say
demand the masks be taken off and they
will do it and they will even take it to
the next level there's certainly not
going to be any
liability for tucker carlson i'm not
suggesting that nor am i suggesting that
there should be it really raises some
very
uh dangerous questions uh if if just
saying that then would be linked back to
tucker and tucker could get arrested
because someone told someone assaulted
someone else over a mask
that's not what i'm suggesting but there
is no question that given the size of
tucker's audience
it will have an impact and whether this
has any connection to tucker or not we
will never know
but there are you know with great power
comes great responsibility i don't know
who said that that might have been
uh i don't know who said it it might be
from spider-man actually i don't know
but um there there is a responsibility
to understand what would be the
follow-on effects from the things that
you say when you have a platform i try
to think about that every day
and it certainly will have an impact
join the discussion on the david pakman
show subreddit
davidpakman.com reddit
you absolutely have to see this
interview from last night with
california
uh potential california gubernatorial
candidate
caitlyn jenner of course of the
kardashians fame
former olympian as bruce jenner earlier
in life
now caitlyn jenner worth 100 million
dollars
personally by most reports and that
becomes very relevant during the
interview
the current california governor is
democrat gavin newsom
there's an effort to recall gavin newsom
in order to do this
californians need to collect just shy of
1.5
million signatures to have a recall
it appears they've done it they've
collected 1.6 million but those
signatures now
have to be validated uh signers also
have 30 days to say actually i signed it
but i don't want to be on the list
anymore
so at some point relatively soon we will
see
will the recall be happening now if
indeed it happens caitlyn jenner has
announced
uh that she is running caitlyn jenner is
notable
because she is a trans woman and a
republican
although how much she knows about
politics is in question
and you will notice that in this
interview of course the republican party
hasn't been very good to the trans
community many have been outright
hostile to the trans community in many
ways including
on the bathroom issue for years now so
jenner was interviewed last night by
sean hannity
and the combination of completely
unrelatable comments about private jets
with sean hannity
and hannity just looking so
uncomfortable with the interview makes
this one of the most compelling
political interviews in a long time
i was watching these clips over and over
again last night like there's a pruder
film preparing for today
so let's jump right in in this first
clip caitlyn jenner tells us
listen we've got to solve these problems
in california
because you know what my neighbor at my
hangar where i keep my private plane
he's thinking of leaving and i'm
thinking of leaving
if we don't improve things think of the
private plane owners
this you have to see california my
friends are leaving california
actually wearing my hanger the guy
across front of redmond he was packing
up his hangers where are you going
and he says i'm moving to sedona arizona
i can't take it
anymore i can't walk down the streets
and see the homeless
i don't want to leave okay either i stay
and fight
or i get out of here why is no one
talking about the marginalized
oppressed private plane owners thinking
of leaving
this is how bad it is in california guys
the private plane owners
they are having to see homeless people
on the way to their hangar
and that that is just terrible the
private plane owners
are this close to packing up their
private jets
and flying somewhere else and caitlyn
jenner
is going to keep them in california if
elected governor okay so off to a
blazing fast start as you can see
and this is nothing it gets even worse
now
of course caitlyn jenner was asked by
hannity about
transgender girls in sports republicans
know almost nothing about the trans
community
but the two things they know about and
care about are trans bathroom laws
and trans girls in sports those are the
two trans issues for republicans
caitlyn jenner's answer is a complete
mystery to me i've watched this
three times i'm gonna watch it now a
fourth time with you i can't make heads
or tails out of this answer take a look
um i stick with my statements that i
made
um i think we have to make sure
that the integrity of girl sports is
there
i think that's extremely important um
but it's there's more to it than just
what i said because i just said
biological boys in sports
there's more to it than that and i think
in the future i will explain more of
that
but for me as a
a trans woman
i think role models are extremely
important for young people
trans issues people struggle with big
time our suicide rate is nine times
higher than the general public
and um for me to be a role model for
them
to be out there i am running
for governor of the state of california
who would have ever thunked that we've
never even had
a woman uh
governor but some are mad at you that's
that's i don't you know i move on
i want to be a role model and i think
the and to be a leader
and i think the most important thing as
a leader
that you can do is your compassion your
honesty
um and i think that sometimes is very
lacking
in politics so uh
i want to be an example uh to all people
not just trans people
but this is what i on the sports side of
it though why
why did how you came down on the sports
side of the issue
i don't know why to be honest with you i
don't know why they keep asking matt
what do you think sean i don't know
why do they keep asking me that question
uh
great question it is a good question so
what on earth is her position on the
issue of trans girls and sports
imagine being a republican and thinking
this is great
a trans candidate finally we are going
to get clarity
what is caitlyn jenner's position on
trans girls and sports
what would caitlyn jenner do as governor
about trans girls in sports and then you
hear that
and you come out even more confused and
then this is just straight out of a
comedy show
sean hannity asks caitlyn jenner's
position
on forest fires and this is i mean you
know
what on earth would caitlyn jenner know
about that issue but it's a big issue in
california if you're going to run for
governor
of california you need an answer to this
because forest fires really are an issue
and her answer is almost verbatim a
trump answer about oh you've got to do
forest management and would you allow
controlled burns isn't there a science
behind forestry
is that science being ignored in this
state yes because when i watch it
management i lived in santa barbara i
watched hope branch
hope ranch burned down after i had just
left the state yes
um uh yes forest management is extremely
important
yeah just like at my house and it's not
even forest management at my house
the reason my house made it because they
say you have to keep
any brush 50 or 75 feet i think i had 75
feet clearance
when the fires came they just went
around my house so fast
it was gone because it's moving very
fast so
it's almost the same thing for forest
management just a little bit of
preparation
so there it is i mean guys just just do
the forest management
and everything will be fine why this is
so why do we keep talking about this
just manage the forest and that's
it and if you thought that was trumpian
in this next clip caitlyn jenner
takes credit for governor gavin newsom
loosening covid restrictions which is
completely out of the trump playbook
take credit for things that have nothing
to do with you and the really funny
thing is jenner says you know if i were
governor i'd open the state tomorrow
if the recall happens it's months away
california's opening in five weeks
so the caitlyn jenner would open the
state tomorrow
except the recall is months away and
california will be open by then take a
look
would you open the state of california
completely tomorrow
absolutely open it right up actually you
know what it's
just don't close in and out burger
before i leave it's even on a small
scale kind of working already
about three weeks ago uh it was rumored
and rightfully so it was rumored that i
was looking in to run for governor
the next day gavin newsom has a press
conference says the state is opening up
july 15th i'm laying there in bed and
watching this and i'm saying yes
it's already working so there it is
caitlyn jenner
may be responsible for covid
restrictions loosening in july
all bizarre and then hannity
asks jenner for an assessment of
trump biden and harris when this
happened i you know i got the popcorn
and got got ready
and her explanation about why trump good
biden bad it's the exact
meaningless vapid drivel we hear from
trumpists take a look at this
we've had four years of donald trump we
have joe biden and kamala harris
give me your assessment of those three
people
um what i liked about donald trump
as he was a disrupter you know
he came in and shook the system up
okay a lot of people didn't like that in
washington d.c but he came in and shook
the system up
i think he did some things that i agreed
with some things i didn't agree with i
you're critical on transgender issues on
trans issues lgbt issues i was more
hopeful at the beginning
um and but there were some good things
he did
on the other hand biden i don't think
i've agreed with anything i don't think
since he's been in there he has um done
anything for the american worker maybe
other ones so
um it is a it is a 180 degree turn in
our country
uh going the other direction and and uh
it scares me it's almost verbatim what
we've heard from for a long time
trump was different he shook things up
he wasn't a politician it was a new
direction
it's just meaningless vapid dribble
once again and then maybe my favorite
clip
of the entire interview this is the
wrap-up hannity
thanks caitlyn jenner for doing the
interview
and jenner brings up the private plane
again and says
let's go for a flight and hannity just
looks
visibly uncomfortable caitlyn jenner
thank you for being with us
it was my pleasure always a pleasure to
talk to you good to see you again
now we're going to go find my plane
around the corner i'm going to take you
for a flight
i'm going right his wheels up any minute
all right all right
uh thank you for the time uh we do wish
you nothing but the best we're going to
follow this race closely
so there it is just a strange interview
trumpian in many ways
completely lacking in substance
completely absent was
any serious policy discussion and i
watched this entire thing
i don't know why caitlyn jenner is
running for governor it's not clear to
me
what caitlyn jenner brings to the table
as a gubernatorial candidate but seeing
republicans
on the one hand they want to remove
gavin newsom
but at the same time many of them
dislike trans people
as much as they dislike gavin newsom and
now they've got a transgender republican
candidate i guess running if the recall
ends up happening
they're in a tizzy they don't know up is
down down is up it's bizarro world for
them so we're going to follow the
california situation
very interesting to see and one of the
most unusual interviews i've ever seen
we'll have clips of it on our instagram
page as well
follow us there at david pakman show
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world-famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
it's great to welcome back to the show
today cal newport who's a computer
science professor
at georgetown university author of
several books and most recently which i
just finished
a world without email reimagining work
in an age of communication overload
cal it's always great to have you on
yeah i'm happy to be back
so um in the book uh a world without
email
one of the things you explain is that
many jobs even jobs
that don't really have to do with email
in terms of what the main
impetus of the job is have become
20 30 40 sometimes even more than half
managing an inbox responding to emails
in a way that is
anywhere from relatively to completely
unproductive you
talk about the history of this and it's
really interesting because
when email was introduced to office
culture you didn't just have
office culture and work culture as it
existed with the addition of email
it completely changed the way that work
worked
so to speak can you talk a little bit
about that first
this is what caught us off guard in the
world of work that when we brought email
into our offices
which we did predominantly in the first
half of the 1990s that's when it really
spread aggressively
through offices we did so for very
narrow pragmatic reasons
we were replacing fax machines we were
replacing voicemail
we were replacing memos it's like great
this tool
is better at those purposes than the
existing technology we were using
once email actually got into offices
though it had an
unexpected side effect which is people
began using it as the primary means by
which they
coordinated or collaborated we
introduced a workflow
in which everything began to be worked
out with back and forth informal ad hoc
messaging that didn't scale and soon we
found ourselves
overwhelmed with all of the back and
forth messages required to support this
workflow where everything happens
through back and forth messaging and
it's really that workflow
not the tool itself not the way that it
replaced fax machines not the way it
replaced voicemail but this workflow
where we began to work everything out
with back and forth messages
that's what created the overload problem
that we're all suffering from today
to some degree it seems almost like
it's become background in this
particular sense my mom also
is a college professor and she's been
teaching for decades at this point and i
asked her in preparation for this
interview
you know back like in the in the 90s
before you were so dependent on email
for communication with your department
and communication with students and so
on
uh what consumed your day because
roughly you're working the same amount
of time but now a ton of the time is
email clearly the email time now
was for something else before she had no
idea like in other words it's sort of
crept
in in such a way where she agrees i work
roughly the same amount
i didn't used to do the email thing now
i do i don't remember what i did before
is is that surprising to you or does
that make sense
well i think we should not underestimate
the degree to which
this workflow in which now we have to
attend these inboxes all day
is really actually putting its hand down
firmly on economic growth
and looking at a college professor is a
it's a good uh
bottle case study because it's a it's a
job that has been basically the same for
200 years and in my book i talked about
my grandfather was was a great example
a very successful professor endowed
chair at rice university that went on to
be the provost of a theological seminary
incredibly productive such an effective
teacher that even to this day
i still hear from his former students he
he had such a big impact on his life
he never owned a computer until after he
retired and i'm thinking
his objectives were no different than my
objectives as a professor today to do
research in the teach well
and he had no email and yet today we'll
spend like your your mom was talking
about 50 to 60
of our time on email it's a real issue
so what is getting squeezed out here i
think productive output
i think the reason why non-industrial
productivity metrics have been stagnant
for decades even as we put
all this innovation into very rapid low
friction communication and computation
technology
is because we are moving more and more
of our time and just tending this
communication and i think what we have
to do to compensate for that is we're
adding extra work
off the books we're working early in the
morning we're working in the evening
like we're basically trying to just keep
productivity stable
by adding a lot more hours into the mix
it's a huge issue and it's one i think
we're ignoring
one approach to the issue and some of
your past writing has sort of dealt with
this and
and there's many other people who write
about this is about techniques and
strategies
um train others to expect that you check
email
once a day or at the beginning at the
end or three times a week or whatever
and over time
that's going to help everybody or uh
write your emails
in a way where you are providing the
other person everything they need to
complete the task
rather than communicating the minimum
which then creates a back and forth over
a week for something that a five-minute
phone call might be able to fix that's
one approach like the very nitty-gritty
logistical approach
that doesn't seem to me like it really
gets at the bigger picture issue what do
you think that we need to be
tackling both the big picture and the
nitty-gritty
or could the nitty gritty really solve a
lot of the problem
the nitty gritty alone is not going to
solve the problem and and this is why i
think we're stuck
is we've been trying to solve the issue
of email overload in the inbox itself
oh spend less time checking emails batch
your emails have better subject lines
write have better norms have better
expectations
but we can't solve this problem this is
one of my the sort of the big idea of
the new book is we can't solve this
problem just in the inbox
the issue is the underlying workflows so
long as
implicitly the way that your
organization collaborates is through ad
hoc back and forth unscheduled messages
the demand to keep up with all these
back and forth threads
demands that you check your inbox all
the time because that is how your work
is actually happening this is why when
we don't change that underlying
workflow but just say have better habits
when you personally interact with your
inbox
that fails so my big push now is to get
past this this moment we're in which
we're
extremely subduing our productivity
because of all the constant context
shifting and communication
we have to fix the underlying workflows
that is the rules and the guidelines and
the agreements we have about how
collaboration happens
it can't just be rock and roll and email
rock and roll and slack rock and roll
and teams will just figure it out
that does not work it is a bad way to
build the metaphorical cars if you know
what i mean
and so we have to fix this at that level
before the messages get into the inbox
in the first place
in the book you talk about fixing it
within an organization in terms of the
communication with co-workers
and it's sort of different at least than
fixing it when it comes to people you
interface outside of your organization
like for example
consultants working with clients which
you include examples of in the book
does it make sense to first fix it
internally
before doing it externally both of these
can happen in parallel
it doesn't quite matter that what really
matters is having that mindset shift
which is saying okay our work is made up
of processes we might not call it that
but that's what they are the things we
do on a regular basis that produce the
value for our team our organization our
company okay
how are we implementing these processes
how do we get the information where do
we store the information how do we
communicate with each other to actually
accomplish these processes what are our
rules for that
and if you don't have rules written down
the default answer is probably
this hyperactive hive mind approach of
we'll just work it out on the fly
once you have that mindset yeah you're
going to see those client communication
processes
let's make those better they're internal
processes how do we schedule meetings
how do we agree on new copy for ads
you fix those processes but the big step
here is that mindset
shift that even in knowledge work
there's things you do again and again
and either you have rules about how you
want to collaborate to accomplish those
things or you don't and if you don't
you're probably leaving a huge amount of
productivity on the table
one of the things you talk about in the
book is that when people
in the knowledge work space are
presented with this idea
in almost invariably they react by
saying okay yeah that might work
in industries a b c and d but i'm in a
more unique position
in my particular job in my particular
field with my particular company
this really wouldn't work uh and and
that belief
seems to be a very prevalent can you
talk
a little bit more specifically about the
types of changes
that probably would work in just about
any knowledge work field
well i think one of the problems here is
that when people think about
reforming email they think about okay
what if nothing
changed about the underlying workflow
when they're imagining they're imagining
their work
as it happens right now in their
organization where most things are
figured out with back and forth
messaging right and then they say
in that context if i stopped using email
as much
bad things would happen and they're
right if your organization or team uses
this hyperactive hivemind workflow
it would be a problem if you stopped
using it so getting people to look below
the inbox
and say no no we want to fix how you
collaborate in the first place so those
messages
don't show up in your inbox that you're
not figuring things out with unscheduled
messages
and we get down to the roots of it so
what do those changes look like
it depends on the process right so this
is why this is not a it's not a tool
discussion
uh it's a non-sequitorious question to
say well if not emailed in what tool
completely it's not the question the
question is okay if not this hyperactive
hive mind workflow how else should we
collaborate or
communicate it depends on what you're
doing so sometimes these solutions are
simple plug-in technology fixes if you
have to schedule a bunch of meetings
you should absolutely be using a meeting
scheduling tool
having to go back and forth emails to
find a time to meet is surprisingly
cognitively taxing fine sometimes what
you're talking about is a process that's
very
rigorously defined it's the same steps
one after another this is what we do to
produce our podcast episode every week
it's seven steps one follows the others
those can often be automated in such a
way that no one has to send unscheduled
messages back and forth to stuff moves
from
place the place people see it without
having to do unscheduled messaging
and sometimes these fixes are about
making information and collaboration
more structured so all the information
for this project is on a shared task
board that we can all look at
we have highly structured status
meetings that are 15 minutes long where
it's what were you working on last time
how did it go
what are you working on today what do
you need to get that done great we'll
talk again tomorrow
so very structured check-ins very
structured ways of storing the
information
that's sort of the third category of
what these process overhauls look like
so
the particular tools or rules or guides
depends on
what's the specific process that you're
overhauling but the thing that unifies
this all
is looking at all the processes in your
work life and saying how do we reduce
all of this back and forth unscheduling
messaging for each of them
you know one of the things i was
thinking of as i read the book
was that um there's a sort of maybe
parallel
issue or question here which is one
that's been written about a lot in the
last five to seven years of
attention span and there are very
differing views on this issue i think
i've read a lot of uh
near ayal's work where he says he
doesn't think that fundamentally there
is an attention span
issue but that the issues are something
different and there's others who say no
you know the the mobile phones and the
email and all of these things
have conditioned people in some way to
for it to be more and more difficult to
spend longer periods of time
focused on one thing is there some way
in which
this entire email thing of 30 40 50
of your day is dipping in and out of
answering emails quickly
to get breaks from the more serious work
may be connected less to systems
but to this attention span issue yeah
it's an important question because i see
a clear separation
between what's happening let's say with
our phones the attention span issue with
social media online news wanting to
continually go back to my phone and be
distracted
yeah where you have tools that are
engineered that try to distract you i
see that as very separate from what's
happening with us having to check email
all the time
okay now it has been common to look at
email through the lens
of a sort of personal addiction for
example when the hyperactive hyphen
workflow first took off in the 2000s we
introduced terminology like crackberries
to
refer to people checking their
blackberries all the time but i'm
convinced
based on my research that the reason
we're checking email all the time it's
not
a failure a personal will it is not an
escape from
work that is uh difficult it is because
the underlying workflow what i call the
hyperactive hive mind
demands it if most of the way that
things get worked out or collaboration
occurs in your organizations with
unscheduled back and forth messages
there is no other way to successfully
interface with your organization than to
constantly be checking those inboxes
because that's what you need to do to
keep knocking these metaphorical tennis
balls back across the net to keep these
ongoing asynchronous ad hoc
conversations going
so when it comes to email i don't think
the issue is that people have bad habits
i think the issue is that organizations
are running in nonsensical ways
um last last thing i want to touch on uh
you talk in the book about how
many of the tasks that are now
distributed throughout the day
for a knowledge worker or professional
of of different kinds
at some previous point might have been
handled by either an assistant
secretary or a position that now is
essentially no longer needed
to me that seems like a huge cost
reduction
for many companies is that an economic
reality
that will resist the types of changes
you're talking about because it is so
much
less expensive or is the counter that
the lost productivity because a lot of
these professionals are doing these
things
throughout the day essentially outweighs
the cost savings of
not having the assistant or the
secretary i think the latter is true
and there are some studies that actually
quantify this one of the studies i talk
about in the book
was watching the arrival of personal
computers and the collection of fortune
500 companies and
what they saw and what they observed in
this research is that yes they fired a
lot of the support staff
because technically the computer made it
easy enough
to do a lot of the things that the
support staff was doing that the
frontline executives could do it
themselves but this researcher
he actually tracked the numbers and
found out that they ended up having to
hire
more of the much higher paid executives
to get the same amount of work done
because so much of their day now was
spent doing things like word processors
and communication etc
that the salary cost went up so they
saved salary costs by firing support
staff
but then increased salary costs by
having to hire more people to get the
same amount of work done and they ended
up worse off because these salaries were
higher
i think we missed the mark on the
digital productivity revolution as
technology made certain
administrative tasks easier the right
move was not to
move all of that work onto the plate of
the the
executives or frontline value producers
it should have been to make it
cheaper to have support staff i think
the right application of that of that
technology would be oh
fewer support staff can now support more
of the frontline workers that was
probably the right way to to
approach the productivity revolution in
terms of maximizing return instead we
said
let's fire the support workers and make
everyone a part-time administrative
assistant and a part-time whatever their
main job
is we know the way the brain works that
that is a that was a bad mix so i think
we really missed the mark on this
digital productivity
revolution it does make us much more
productive
if we use that to actually empower
support staff to be even more effective
not to put more things on the plate of
the people that you wanted thinking
about the ad copy or making the
executive decisions or writing the
academic papers or whatever it is you
had hired them to do
right uh that it's it's a fascinating
book the book is a world without
email reimagining work in an age of
communication overload you know i find
that so often
when i talk to people about this book
other books you've written and and other
there's this visceral reaction like that
would never work we shouldn't even be
thinking about that do you do you see
this is that is that a common reaction
from a lot of people
well i think the key thing with this
book is understanding that
you're changing the workflow because as
soon as you say just you
need to spend less time on email they're
so overwhelmed by this hyperactive hive
mind workflow they're like are you
kidding me
i would be dead because everything is
happening in the inbox but the real aha
moment for most people is when you say
yeah the reason why that's happening is
because the underlying agreements by how
work happens is generating all these
messages
and it doesn't have to be that way and
you tell them about companies where they
don't use email
and they don't use slack and they don't
have an inbox to check and they do one
thing at a time and maybe they work on
three things each day and when you show
them those stories
you can just see the light turn on
behind their eyes so
i think that's key the way we work today
makes it impossible not to check email i
agree
we can fix the underlying way we work
though we've been speaking with cal
newport
computer science professor at georgetown
university we'll link to the latest
book a world without email cal always
great having you on
thanks david the david pakman show
depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and one way to
keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
okay this you really have to see on fox
and friends yesterday morning their
one of their three hosts brian kilmeade
was reduced to arguing with children
about trump versus biden
in a segment that if he was able to feel
shame
he should be completely humiliated by
his participation in this segment an 11
year old kid
pretty accurately makes the case that
he's feeling better
about getting back to school and about
handling the pandemic
now that joe biden is president and is
dealing with the coronavirus in a
serious way
completely reasonable position it's an
11 year old kid kill mead
sort of seems to crack he didn't like
the kid's comment i guess
and he sort of like responds rudely to
the kid it's very weird take a look at
this
how close are you to getting back in the
room what do you miss most about not
being in school
um i miss most obviously seeing my
friends
and all the after school activities that
i've done and i think that
we're very very close getting back to
school and
i think that um the way that
our new president is handling things is
a very good way and we would not have
gone
to this if it were still the last
president
really that's hard to believe because
the last president was saying i want
every kid back in school
so lily for you what is your hope
knowing the numbers are going down and
the governor might be opening up
did you notice that kilmeade even moved
on to the next kid right away
before the 11 year old could refute
kilmeade's completely flaccid
counterpoint he doesn't want the kid to
say another word
now a source at fox news told me after
the interview kilmeade referred to the
kid as a poopy head
and that seems on brand with the way
this entire segment went
who thought this was a good idea who who
conceives of this segment and thinks
it's a good idea
and if it wasn't killmead and the
segment was put in front of him
why not react by saying interesting it's
so great that you're involved in
following what's going on what a can can
brian kilmeade
feel anything but complete and total
shame over
this segment or at least should he who
wants to bet that this kid's parents
end up getting threats as a result of
this segment that's the serious thing
and unfortunately uh it wouldn't be
even remotely surprising to me and again
why even try to counter what an 11 year
old is saying
if you strongly refute a kid you're
beating an 11 year old in a debate
and of course if the kid makes more
sense than you which was actually the
case here
you really look like a [ __ ] and it's
almost like that game
show are you smarter than a fifth grader
or a sixth grade or whatever
it's the fox news edition of that game
show and the hosts are losing badly
like imagine feeling the urge to debate
and disprove
rather than encourage a kid for their
involvement in what's going on in the
world around them
and this is how propaganda motivates
people to behave
every differing opinion it doesn't
matter how minor
it doesn't matter how non-threatening
the purveyor of the opinion is it is
perceived as a threat
that must be dealt with immediately you
know interesting
thanks for sharing your opinion it's
great to see kids involved in their
country
taking an interest great no no instead
killmead
argues and then argues with and then
cuts off
an 11 year old kid now i'm being totally
serious here this is not
i'm not joking about this if you
replaced killmeade with this 11 year old
on fox and friends it would be a way
better and more interesting show i might
become a regular viewer of fox and
friends if
this kid was mixing it up with steve
ducey and ainsley earhart instead of
brian kilmeade
that would make it a better show and i'm
not kidding when i say
the kid seems better informed than most
of the fox news audience i have no doubt
whatsoever about that
now for a moment let's deal with the
substance of brian kilmeade's rebuttal
kilmeade is right trump said open every
school and put every kid back in school
it was the middle of a pandemic we had
not nearly enough testing
no guidelines about how to safely open
schools absent vaccination
and we had no vaccines we had no
precautions we had no preventive
measures trump just said
open it all up it's true trump said it
but it would have been insanely
dangerous to open schools when and how
donald trump said he wanted to do it
and fortunately it didn't happen now joe
biden is doing it
and it's being done safely and it's
abund but abundantly clear
who got the right side of that argument
it wasn't killmead it was the 11 year
old kid
as we reported to you yesterday
donald trump's facebook ban has been
reduced from indefinite to
we will review it in six months but it
was not ended yesterday for anybody
thinking trump might be back on facebook
yesterday from that perspective
the ban was extended as expected
republicans
fox news right-wing media don jr even
donald trump himself
from his new blog have been melting down
over this decision we're going to go
through it and we're going to point out
what are some really truly terrible
arguments so that you
will be prepared when you hear these or
see these on facebook or at the water
cooler
are water coolers even coveted safe now
i don't know first donald trump himself
who published to his new communication
social media platform
which i know as a as a blog he published
the following message
this is trump what facebook twitter and
google have done
is a total disgrace and an embarrassment
to our country now he's wrong about that
the embarrassment are the actions of
trump that led to his being banned
including inciting a riot on january 6th
trump goes on to say free speech has
been taken away
from the president of the united states
because the radical left lunatics are
afraid of the truth
but the truth will come out anyway
bigger and stronger than ever before
this is not really a free speech issue
and we've talked about that before and
we'll talk about it in a minute
so i won't spend too much time on that
trump then going on to say the people of
our country will not stand for it
these corrupt social media companies
must pay
a political price and must never again
be allowed to destroy
and decimate our electoral process
i don't know what kind of a price trump
is talking about a political price like
maybe
regulation which trump is against next
example here is donald trump's former
chief of staff mark meadows on fox news
saying that it is a sad day for america
and this might actually make republicans
in congress enforce
the antitrust laws already on the books
that they never cared about until now
this is just the best take a look
the oversight board will uphold the ban
on donald trump
your reaction yeah it's a sad day for
america it's a sad day for facebook
because i can tell you a number of
members of congress are now
looking at do they break up facebook do
they make sure that they don't have a
monopoly
and i can tell you that it is two
different standards
one for donald trump and one for a
number of other people that are on their
sites and
and suggesting that uh uh
more nefarious things than what the
president has been accused of
actually go unnoticed often and so this
is a sad day for america but a saturday
for
uh uh the the facebooks of the world who
have actually enjoyed a very
wild wild west kind of regulatory
environment
i can tell you that's going to change
the discussion will happen within hours
of this decision on capitol hill just a
few few blocks
from where i am now there is a real
conversation here
about the reality that the united states
has had anti-trust laws
on the books for a long time there has
been no interest in the u.s
politically in enforcing them i've been
talking about this issue for years
we've done interviews about it the
republicans never cared
before about enforcing antitrust
antitrust enforcement is regulation
which they are against
suddenly now these hypocrites care about
antitrust they are transparently
pathetic
the next clip i would play would be of
donald trump jr on stephen crowder's
program
from what i understand crowder is really
aggressive with copyright strikes on
youtube so i'm not going to play the
clip
but as crowder tweeted don jr told him
that quote
the facebook oversight board holding up
the trump suspension says a lot
about the powers of companies like
facebook i imagine the board doesn't
have a lot of people who share our views
it's an echo chamber of silicon valley
now
same thing again they suddenly care
about antitrust
now that they think it would help them
to enforce it but they never cared
for decades about all of the
monopolistic behavior that could have
been stopped by enforcing the laws
already on the books
next clip is from newsmax here is susan
wright
susan is a trump endorsed republican
candidate for congress
listen to what she says this obviously
making waves with so many conservative
voices here as they felt silence along
the way
and this ban uh speaks volumes
uh your thoughts on it when you saw that
breaking news
well i haven't read nearly as much about
it as uh as i will of course
throughout the day but i will tell you
that this um
this censorship that the tech giants are
engaging in
is outrageous it is absolutely
outrageous
i don't support it i think that uh
you know you have to really wonder who
who is making these decisions it's very
subjective there's some things they
censor and some things they don't
there's a lot of radical groups on
facebook and other social media
platforms
who don't seem to be censored at all but
conservative groups and conservative
voices are continually censored
continually pushed back
and continually vilified in congress
i'll do everything i can to
to shut that effort down and
and push back on them as well she hasn't
read about it
but it's definitely censorship who is
making these decisions
for profit companies that republicans
like
you susan wright have said for the last
hundred years should
should never be uh regulated and should
be allowed to make whatever decisions
they want that's who's making the
decisions
just another painfully hypocritical
troll
and by the way censorship of
conservative voices on facebook
the top clips on facebook almost every
day
are ben shapiro dan bongino
sean hannity other fox news clips other
fox news hosts it's almost
all right wingers that dominate the top
clips on facebook
last one republican congressman peter
king
says this violates free speech take a
listen
uh congressman king we'll start with you
your reaction to this ruling
by facebook to uphold the ban for
president trump at least temporarily
i think it's unfortunate we even have to
discuss this i think it's outrageous
what facebook has done and i would say
the same it was bernie sanders or
hillary clinton
to me uh whether or not there's a
constitutional right and it could be a
legal right here because of all the
legal benefits and
coverages and exemptions reliability
that congress has given
to these platforms and to facebook and
twitter but
uh i first of all i think facebook is
wrong president is going to get his own
platform that's going to work but i just
think
congress has to look at this i think
this is analogous to we had
in the beginning of the last century
with inside trust i'm sure
you know consumers can make a choice but
it's not a real choice because you have
a few
and there it is consumers can make a
choice but it's not a real choice
and it's a free speech issue and it's
time to enforce antitrust what a
principled statement from peter king
right
do not fall for it it's only about
how does it affect them right now that's
all that this is about
every single one of these arguments
hypocritically
and obviously not an argument they made
until they thought we got to get trump
back on twitter and facebook and all of
a sudden these are the arguments they're
now making don't fall for it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh here is the eggman weighing in on the
plan for some sports stadiums
to have vaccinated and unvaccinated
sections take a listen
hi dave i hear that in the opening of
large uh sporting
arenas and stuff you're going to try to
be inclusive to people that are
unvaccinated and they're going to make
vaccinated people sit in one area
and unvaccinated people sit in another
area
i feel that is a complete recipe for
disaster
and it reminds me of when i was in italy
and i was seeing a soccer game it was
uh verona versus chievo verona right two
super enemy opposing teams and they seat
you
by which team that you root for so they
seek to
each side and separate sides of the
arena separated by a big
fence people were throwing cups of urine
weapons any bot anything you could think
that were on fire
there was anything you could name was
landing over and on my head from the
opposing team and i'm just imagining
the unvaccinated and vaccinated people
just fighting with each other
inside a sporting arena when one of
their teams lost
am i imagining things or could this
really happen shalom brother
yes of course shalom to the eggman yeah
i've experienced similar things you know
soccer games in argentina it's sort of a
similar situation
yeah i don't love it i would rather see
the stadiums take a more
definitive approach and say we want to
get back to full capacity and the way to
do it is
we're only going to allow vaccinated
people in because what some stadiums are
doing is
if you're vaccinated there will be one
section with full capacity every seat
can be full
in another section the unvaccinated
section they will only have every third
seat occupied
um one one for one person for every
three seats and
there's a bunch of different reasons i
don't like it what the eggman is talking
about is certainly a factor
uh but just just take a stand if you
believe clearly you believe vaccination
is safer because you allow people to sit
together
you don't on the unvaccinated side just
say for not only for safety but also as
a business decision
we want to fill every seat and the way
to do it safely is with everybody
being vaccinated let's see if every
teams make that decision if any teams
make that decision we have a great bonus
show for you today
the alleged capital rioters are still
being arrested to this day they're still
finding more and more of them
a california bar owner has been busted
for making
phony vaccination cards and a federal
judge has overturned
the national eviction ban
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
don't miss it get instant access and i
really do mean instant the speed of
light
uh by signing up at joinpackman.com i'll
see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman